i have
run out of intros this is what i'm doing
now okay
leave your entries in the subreddit
grab your favorite minecraft merch and
let's get it gamers
what is happening 12-hour minecraft live
stream at 100 million subscribers come
on gamers
it's my favorite part of the week after
playing minecraft
reviewing the live memes oh yes finally
bing bong bing bing bong heard my new
minecraft house
is epic so that was a freaking little
one
you know if you want to be mad be mad at
snipe that's right right side i'm
blaming you
it was his idea i was like psy what's
good idea of thumbnail
i think at least i don't remember was it
yeah it's sightful
mr beast speaking the language of gods
make sure you limit your video game time
today i don't want you to become super
violent
remember before games war wasn't a thing
love him or hate him let's get real
everyone love him mr beast
spitting facts pewdiepie i think my
humor has become less childish over the
years
you think you're better than fart noises
no one's better than fart noises let's
get real here 12 hour minecraft live
stream
at 100 million oh here we go okay
are we at 99 yet come on gamers
minecraft vicky
felix trying to beat the wither using
zombie pigmen the wither is immune to
all attacks from
other undead mobs except skulls from
other withers damn it well here's the
thing i knew
okay i just thought there would be a
good decoy there were other people
saying that they healed them and that
confused me as well but
they definitely serve their purpose okay
thank you pigmen
very great hey guys so today we finally
built the cobblestone
generator yeah i think uh i think
it's time me and can play something else
in minecraft we're still stuck on the
cobblestone
this is otherwise it's this episode 500.
at this point sven has entered the
nether twice okay
kill two llamas okay enter the freaking
room
okay all without felix permission just
like a rebel teenager
when he's growing up this is so cute he
also
got married meanwhile in hong kong
throughout the protests
pew news save us oh my god what do i
have to do
i'll call papa gloria she's been on
vacation she's been having a good time
i'll get her on this stack she's been
playing minecraft
when you forget to refrigerate your
meatball
i don't like this i didn't even realize
what am i gonna do
do i have to climb the meatball what do
i gotta do people said i should put the
red sauce on it like
i should put like red carpet over it you
dumbbells you're a bunch of dumbbells
okay
that's the worst suggestion i've ever
heard in my life swedish people don't
put tomato sauce on their meatballs
that's italians
you dummy dum dum we put brown sauce on
our meatballs
honestly you should probably just delete
your youtube account whoever made that
comment
oh my god that is the cutest
who made this the kiwa thank you very
much that's really cute
sven will appreciate we can use sven's
gray scared foreshadowing noises
see i noticed it even when i was editing
i said it like three times in a row and
i
i let one in because i needed a sentence
now i'm starting to understand what it's
like to be an editor
and having to cut through my speech
impediment jesus christ
i can say freak as many times as i want
youtube
what are you gonna do people were saying
that they got a mineral ad while i said
frick freak frick what are you gonna do
youtube freak freak thinking
you can't stop the frickening you can
stop scared pewdiepie but you can't stop
the freaking name
grandpa i found your old stuff what is
it it's a dance man
i'm gonna dare you a great story what
you name your child sven after sven dog
wow what is this poor pee pee poo poo
felix excusing the pee pee poop
armor for healing the weather during the
second phase the
poopoo armory knowing that the weather
regenerates during the second phase
why did no one tell me everyone is going
don't summon him by the house that's all
i heard
no actual help you should sleep in the
nether felix
can't trust you jeb in heaven watching
felix literally making a sex turn
what oh yeah a
freak dungeon get it right gamer gaming
week
gaming month minecraft addiction
good morning gamers this is the daily
episode 6934 minecraft micro
mazia passed away but at least i have
said
oh this is so sad oh
i'm a terrible parent the green parent
the felix trap
waiting for felix oh my god
i'm so sorry
i need to retrieve him now the perfect
birthday party
doesn't exist why we is that redstone
what does redstone taste like red
or that shoots you have 100 million
youtube subscribers
what's your next video it's not the
beautiful day
no one's gonna want anything else let's
get real here come on gamers
12 hour lifetime at 100 million
subscribe end credit scene after
pewdiepie beats the wither
fine i'll do it myself i love how epic
that was
legit i was tearing up myself editing
that i appreciate all the nice comments
me when i'm scrolling through this
subreddit without watching the latest
video
i'm always so confused fake fan didn't
watch the latest video fake fan
you see you need an extremely high iq to
understand pewdiepie
okay the lore goes extremely in depth
her he's probably thinking about other
villagers him
what if pewdiepie actually got the job
he applied for at mojang
and the job was to become a youtuber
again and gain a large
enough platform to revive the game after
it initially lost popularity
oh my god can you imagine how much
minecraft gained from not hiring me
because instead i just went and became a
youtuber and helped promote the game
the cape you saw on minecraft character
is not because of your resource pack
optifine has an add-on called capes with
this you can wear capes in minecraft
and i give you mine what
that's so sweet thank you that explains
a lot i was so confused
pee pee
my first post here well you started off
extremely strong you're never gonna beat
this one trust me
when you realize that if we never told
felix about sven's tale health bar swine
would most likely be dead
it ain't much but it's honest work thank
you gamers
it is actually really helpful because
it's the only animal that indicates it
isn't it
not knowing anything about fitness and
firm i still don't get it stop
stop posting these what if felix put
both of us in the freaking chamber lol
just kidding just kidding
unless hey what happens in the frick
chamber stays in the frick chamber
it's nice and soft i think you'll like
it felix look what you've done
jacksepticeye looking good wanna play
minecraft
oh betrayal ah you should use ikea burst
feather and make an
arrow out of it and kill the ender
dragon with it for revenge
that is actually cool but what you nerds
don't know is that
ender dragon is immune to arrows so uh
cringe did you guys just post cringe i'm
a minecraft veteran and even i knew that
today's episode was freaking beautiful
oh it was from a few days ago
thank you guys swedish people's first
name swedish people's
last day what is it now like
eight years anytime here in uk what is
your name
kajelberg casulberg
and then you come back to sweden and be
like oh mr shelburg ah
feels so good petition to name the place
where felix keep the villagers
the ranch that is actually a good idea i
like that we could build a giant dr phil
face
oh my god yes i saw this
we both had the same dumb ass face
as well big brother
this is what happens when you're a
minecraft veteran brain goes infinity
and beyond
no don't do this stop please
i don't get it nobody's born cool except
of course
the person that brought felix that
swedish game
i agree i agree gamers helping gamers
i can't believe this is the same person
that made a two-time
two by two piston door and automatic
phone
i don't get it either for some reason
whenever i play with other people
jack is the same brain just goes ex
insanely big
get in the boat
last thing you hear before you never see
your family again imagine one day you're
you're in your garden some swedish guy
walks up behind you hey what a nice farm
you got there
that's when you know it's over you can
put stained glass on a beacon
to make it different colors thank you i
know this you should know that i already
know this
i like the creeper in the back too
that's good appearance made an oopsy
oh man i thought people would get mad at
me for like changing the weather
i know i said like i'll never use
creative mode but clearly for some stuff
it seems like it's necessary i won't use
it for building okay
or getting material let me guess you're
home
it was and it was beautiful you know
everyone lost their mind over the fact
that i summoned the weather in my base
despite the fact that people going for
days
don't do it don't summon the wither in
your base you know the aftermath
really wasn't that bad i kind of hope to
have like a marvel avengers
like aftermath of battle kind of thing
like maybe the meatball had blown up
i was like that would look cool that
would be like oh wow really cinematic
and epic
nope nothing happened stupid death
the golden one stupid death 2 the
diamond one
died like a hero the dirt one what
oh my god yes
i don't know what youtube is gonna do
it'd be cool if they did something like
that
that's so cool magma blocked me
oh that's really funny yeah i don't know
how i got that to 41 minutes
like it's seriously hard to get them
that long i printed felix minecraft
world
damn that's awesome
i can't power look so good wow
pewds villagers 0.001 seconds after
potatoes start
falling from the ceiling why the [ __ ]
yep just an idea for when dinner bone
you know
hey no 14 year old boy is talking about
girls so apparently
if you throw food in there it makes it
i mean it's true it works my freaking
chamber is going to be the most advanced
thing ever oh my god yeah i didn't
notice this for so long
that's so awesome i should have called
them like gur
jun or something yeah i'm good with
names i don't know what to tell you
brad editing sive edited
i love how it makes me look just insane
pewds in his own survival series beards
and skyblock there it is
see i don't i'll blame ken i'll blame
ken i don't care about area 51 if
youtube rewind
doesn't have jurgen sven or anything
about minecraft we raid youtube oh they
will definitely have something about
minecraft
put a tribute to ikea bird on your
shoulder
that's such a good idea oh my god yes
yes absolutely ikea bird has died like
four times
i don't know if i already reacted to
this but it's so good
i'm like the dumbest person i would like
i would like to say the dumbest smart
person but no i'm just dumb
ulabrita mitzvah you know full well what
this means don't you
yes yes for i have accepted the offering
they're stealing the fate of swedish
man's hands i will now
accept the fair consequences even if it
means my own demise may what a ship
the drama what is this what is
this i don't get it yet stop calling my
meatball moldy
stop stop it now stop yeah this is
this is what i was getting at earlier
youtube rewind will probably just make
minecraft cringy again
please please youtube you don't have to
have me in it
just just don't ruin minecraft please i
love all the fan art of taking like
a small thing that happened and making
it like
a thing felix spawning with her inside
base he actually kills it without
destroying his face
and the third one he's disappointed that
he didn't destroy his base
that's not what i meant relax how i
accidentally hit my younger brother
still
touched one how my brother tell him mom
i hit him
sharpness five
that's good i understand this smash like
if you understood this one
don't spawn the wither near your house
that sound can stop me because i can't
read
hey you can't tell me what to do you
lost those privileges
when you killed the first jurgen that's
right i'm not over it
you did it you crazy son of a freak you
did it
oh my god is that many huh oh
no
this is so sad everyone when feeling
feelings
right come on it added tension it had a
drawback you gotta appreciate it
if you don't have high like what do you
want me to do make it everyone's like oh
what you can do is like you can spawn
him in
obsidian and that will make the fight
easy like no no
no pain no gain you got to do it
oh my god there's so many good memes
garden of eden has a freaking chamber
god creates adam and eve also god
what if we all live in the simulation
and pewdiepie
is telling everyone to flee i see you
crying through your front camera but i
don't blame you i'm crying dude
that was beautiful
council of watershed the council will
decide your fate
oh man oh my god gonna prank it
i'll bring him back okay i'll bring him
back okay gamers that's
it for this week's lawyer there's so
many more but i gotta go back playing
minecraft smash like if you enjoyed
if you want to check out protect sven
merch i mean you don't have to but it
would be pretty cringe if you don't have
it next week
i'll finish off with another song by
party in the backyard
and that's it for me for now see you
guys later gamers
[Applause]
[Music]
i will fight all those nasty zombies for
you
my life was almost meaningless before
you here
best friend still the end no one else
can compare we got a bond
unbreakable i love unshakable
[Music]
you can
you can all
[Music]
but we had some dope adventures we
crossed the land and see
in every kind of weather sometimes i
would get lost i can get a bit
distracted but i always knew you'd find
me so it never really mattered
my stable was so epic and jeb was so
pathetic but when dinner bone and broke
out when i did feel empathetic
i saw someone ride the rails and wanted
to have a run so even though it killed
me at least i died having some fun
[Music]
okay
but i think it's safe to say that i'd
rather die again and suffer through
another lonely day
at your place it was horror a disgrace
you have no honest say you miss me now
but in life it was all torture you never
knew the value that i had when i was
living
but now i'm gone you realize what you
were always missing
i was the perfect sheep and now when
you're asleep
you'll dream
[Music]
is
okay
[Music]
and when we ring the bell
what you never played two for simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price